Trascrizione: Cristina Mancuso
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ci sono parole che fanno paura:
una di queste è fallimento, fallire.
Io so che se c'è qualche imprenditore,
adesso in sala, starà toccando ferro;
ma la mia storia
è una storia di fallimenti
ed io ho dedicato 15 anni della mia vita
a fallire proprio bene.
Ho capito che mi piaceva fallire
quando avevo 20 anni:
non sapevo chi ero,
e quindi ho deciso di fare un viaggio,
andare lontano da tutti,
e sono andata in Thailandia.
Non parlavo una parola di Thailandese,
non sapevo chi ero,
ma sapevo che avevo voglia
di conoscere le persone che avevo intorno.
E quindi ho deciso un giorno
che per farlo dovevo comprare un pallone.
Quindi ho comprato un pallone -
io giocavo a calcio, in Italia -
Sono andata da un gruppo di ragazzini
che c'era in questo paesino
sperduto della Thailandia,
e ho iniziato a giocare
con loro, a calcio.
A un certo punto sono rimasta allibita
perché mi sono resa conto
che tutto il villaggio si era radunato
intorno ai bordi di questo campetto,
in una situazione tipo cinema,
come se fossero al cinema:
solo che il cinema ero io.
Ho superato l'imbarazzo
in quella situazione,
ho continuato a giocare
con tutte le energie che avevo in corpo,
e a un certo punto è successa una cosa
che mi ha cambiato la vita:
sono caduta.
Ma proprio....
bella lì, distesa.
Cosa è successo?
Tutte le persone che c'erano lì, radunate,
all'unisono, sono scoppiate a ridere.
Tutti hanno cominciato a ridere di me.
Io ho alzato lo sguardo,
sono rimasta pietrificata,
avrei voluto che la terra si aprisse
sotto di me e mi mangiasse in un secondo,
ma non è stato così,
e quindi ho fatto l'unica cosa
che potevo fare in quella situazione:
ho riso con loro.
In quel momento, io ho capito
che nella mia vita
avevo finalmente trovato
qualcosa che mi piaceva.
Questa caduta, questo fallimento,
ha segnato in me
una forte presa di coscienza,
e ho capito che volevo fare il clown.
Perché il clown?
Perché il clown mette in scena
la propria vulnerabilità
e i propri fallimenti,
ride con gli altri,
e creando un'empatia magica
trova nuove soluzioni ai problemi.
Questo come lo fa?
Lo fa in una manciata di secondi.
In una manciata di secondi,
quando ridiamo per un clown,
abbiamo tre pensieri a livello inconscio:
il primo è che è un fallito,
abbiamo davanti a noi un idiota
che sta facendo una figuraccia.
Il secondo pensiero inconscio che abbiamo
è che realizziamo, in quel momento,
che anche noi almeno una volta nella vita
abbiamo fatto una figuraccia
per cui avremmo voluto
che la terra si aprisse
e ci ingurgitasse in quell'istante.
La terza cosa, la più importante:
a livello inconscio,
in quella manciata di secondi:
noi ci rendiamo conto
che anche altri stanno ridendo con noi,
che anche altri si sono sentiti,
nella vita, dei falliti.
E questo crea una magia e un'empatia
che applicata alla vita di tutti i giorni
fa succedere delle cose
che, se noi pensiamo a livello razionale,
non le faremmo accadere.
E qui arriva la seconda parte
del mio racconto.
Torno dalla Thailandia;
cara mamma, caro papà,
io voglio fare il clown,
io voglio fallire.
Voi potete capire il dramma familiare
che si creò nella provincia di Milano,
dove sono nata e cresciuta;
ma supero quest'imbarazzo,
vado avanti, e vengo a Torino.
Conosco l'arte di strada, mi formo,
faccio degli stages,
e dei corsi professionali di teatro
e inizio a lavorare anche in strada.
Sempre a Torino,
incontro quella che è diventata
la mia socia di lavoro, Silvia.
Insieme creiamo una compagnia
di teatro di strada, comico, al femminile,
che solo dieci anni fa
era abbastanza una novità.
Questo perché c'erano
anche altre artiste comiche donne,
ma eravamo sicuramente una minoranza.
E quindi grazie a questa cosa, anche,
subito entriamo nel mondo del lavoro,
subito iniziamo a lavorare
e ad essere contattate da festival
ed eventi di teatro di strada.
E qui inizia il nostro vero dramma.
Perché solo dieci anni fa,
voi forse non sapete,
il grado disastroso di percezione
del nostro mestiere che c'era.
A voi, forse, non è mai successo:
alla domanda: "Che lavoro fai?"
- "Mah io sono un'attrice
di teatro di strada: faccio il clown".
La risposta, al 99,9 % delle volte, era:
"Ah, no, interessante!
Ma di lavoro, che lavoro fai?"
E il dramma si consumava anche
nella relazione con i nostri committenti.
Perché vi assicuro che solo dieci anni fa,
fare teatro di strada
e ottenere un contratto per questo lavoro,
sembrava un'impresa degna di Maria Callas,
di una diva del cinema.
Al che, di fronte a questa difficoltà,
cominciamo a riderne insieme, ovviamente,
facendolo di mestiere,
e iniziamo a confrontarci
con altri artisti di strada, qui a Torino.
Ci ridiamo sopra, ne parliamo,
e capiamo che abbiamo bisogno
di un pallone, e ce lo creiamo.
In dieci artisti di strada,
nel 2009 qua a Torino,
fondiamo la prima cooperativa
di artisti di strada.
La prima in tutta Italia:
noi ovviamente non lo sapevamo,
mentre lo stavamo facendo,
ma abbiamo scoperto, negli anni,
che abbiamo risposto
a un'esigenza nazionale.
Infatti da quei dieci, primi,
considerati "pazzi",
ad oggi siamo trecento.
Trecento artisti di strada in tutta Italia
che, grazie alla cooperativa,
ricevono una tutela amministrativa,
legale e contrattuale,
che prima era veramente un traguardo
che sembrava irrangiungibile.
E a conferma del nostro lavoro,
della nostra passione,
e di tutto il nostro impegno e fatica,
tre anni fa abbiamo avuto
un importante riconoscimento:
siamo entrati nel programma
di sostegno del FUS,
riconoscimento ministeriale,
come prima impresa di produzione
di teatro di strada,
prima in Italia ad essere composta,
per il 90 percento,
da artisti stessi e non da committenti.
Che dire adesso?
Voi mi vedete, sono qui
in accappatoio; e c'è un motivo.
Vi presento un piccolo estratto
di uno dei miei fallimenti
con cui ho girato il mondo
e grazie al quale ho capito
che cadere e ridere davanti agli altri
non serve a farmi cadere di meno
ma, nel mio piccolo, ha trasformato
quella caduta in un volo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)